RICH HYNDMAN: Welcome to this
week's Android Developer
Office Hours, live
from London.
Yay!
Today, we're joined by Chris
Banes, Matt Gaunt, Nick
Butcher, and-- duh
da da duh duh--
Ellie Powers from the Google
Play developer consult team.
Ellie's joining us today because
she's got a couple of
announcements she's gonna make
at the top of the show.
As normal--
I'm going to say it's normal.
We won't be making any
announcements, but we will be
making one or two announcements
at the start.
We won't be talking
about [INAUDIBLE]
or any unreleased products.
We have a pretty full Moderator
today, so it's going
to go quite quickly to
get through them all.
I'm going to try and make a note
when we've answered these
questions, so afterwards I can
put a little synopsis under
the YouTube video and make
that even more useful.
So welcome to the guys live
in the Hangout as well.
We've got--
well, you just want to say hi?
I'm too far away to actually
see you [INAUDIBLE] today.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Hi.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
RICH HYNDMAN: Wiebe and Yossi
I recognize over there, and
we've got people piling in.
So welcome to everyone
in the Hangout.
There's Giuseppe as well.
You'll have a chance to ask
some questions shortly.
But for now, we will hopefully
have some information on the
new Play Developer
Console for us.
ELLIE POWERS: Cool.
So we've had a lot of interest
in the new Developer Console.
A lot of people are using it
already, which is great.
And last week, we asked people
what are the things that you'd
be looking for that would
encourage you to use the new
Developer Console.
And so today, we actually
released a number of new
different features, and
most of them haven't
been announced before.
So I guess you're the first
people to find out.
So the Google Play private
channel is now available in
the new Developer Console.
So if your company or
organization is using Google
Apps to distribute--
do we have a happy
guy down there?
I saw some happy guys.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Yes, I am.
ELLIE POWERS: Hey.
So if that was keeping you
from switching to the new
Developer Console, you can now
use that to take certain
applications and distribute them
only within your Google
Apps domain.
So go ahead and use
that right now.
You can find it on the Pricing
and Distribution page, if you
just scroll all the
way to the bottom.
The second thing is that the
announcements module is now on
the new Developer Console, so
you'll be able to get any news
and other pieces of
information that
we're sharing there.
You can find that in the left
side of the navigation.
It looks kind of like a
megaphone, and it lights up
bright orange when there's
a new announcement there.
So you can try clicking on it
and seeing what's in there.
The next thing that we have is
sort of a detail, but many
people, when they get in their
string resources, they don't
know which language codes
correlate with
which language name.
So we're now showing the
language name and also the
language code together, so that
if someone's sending you
a big file, and it's specified
only by the language code, you
can be completely sure that
you're putting it into the
right language.
So that's sort of a detail.
The next thing-- probably, I
think, the most popular change
is a lot of people have been
asking, how do I delete a
draft application?
Maybe you created an
application, oops, it was the
wrong package name.
You've switched, or you just had
some experiments that you
decided not to publish.
So that is now available.
You can find that in the upper
right-hand corner of your
Developer Console, and if you
look in the little menu where
it'll say Draft, you can click
on that, and there should be
an option under there that says
Delete This Application.
RICH HYNDMAN: After
you've done that--
ELLIE POWERS: Sorry?
RICH HYNDMAN: After you've done
that, would you be able
to reuse the package
name again?
Is it completely gone?
ELLIE POWERS: I think so.
I'm not 100% sure about that.
Usually, when people--
I mean, there's no reason why
you would want to do that.
If you have used the package
name, you should just carry on
with that one.
But it's more like, a lot of
people would create the wrong
package name, and then realize
they need to change it.
So if you already have
that package name
in there, it's fine.
You don't have to do anything.
But if you clutter up your
Developer Console, now you can
declutter it.
RICH HYNDMAN: From apps that
have never been published.
ELLIE POWERS: Right.
Once you've published an
application, even if you
unpublish it, you
can't delete it.
But if it's a draft, and it's
never been published,
you can delete it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Just wanted to
say, I tested that feature a
few minutes ago.
ELLIE POWERS: Did it work?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
ELLIE POWERS: Fantastic.
OK, I'm very glad that you
tested that for us.
RICH HYNDMAN: How did you know
the feature was there, Yossi?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, I have
two developer accounts.
One is for Legacy, because the
Israeli market was changed to
the Israel currency,
so I had to open a
new developer account.
And when I tried to log in with
the Legacy one, I had a
message saying I need
to pay $25 again to
register as a developer.
So I paid again, and when I
entered the Developer Console,
I saw all the new features.
Also the megaphone, also the
strings and everything.
ELLIE POWERS: Cool.
We updated the Developer Console
just a couple of hours
ago, so that's--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, so I was
lucky to see all the changes
in real time.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's how
relevant this show is.
ELLIE POWERS: Exactly.
This show is like,
right there.
Did you think it was a dream
that you saw a megaphone that
wasn't there before?
Confirm it here.
And then the other thing that
we've launched today is what
we're calling Statistics
Annotations.
So, a lot of times, when
you're looking at your
statistics graph, you wonder,
why did that go up?
I had a certain number of users,
and then it went up.
Or, I had a rating,
and then it just
dipped all of a sudden.
And a lot of times, that's
because you've
released a new version.
Maybe that new version has
different functionality.
Maybe you fixed some bugs,
and that caused your
rating to go up.
And now we have little dots on
your Statistics page that show
when each of your different
APK versions went out.
So you can just hover your mouse
over your Statistics
page on this little grey dot
that comes up, and it'll say,
OK, that was version number 7,
or that was version number 50.
And you can use that to see if
some of the spikes in your
statistics graph are correlated
with new releases.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Based on your
version code or version name?
ELLIE POWERS: I don't remember
which one it shows.
It definitely shows either
one of the two.
Every APK has both a version
code and a version number.
I don't remember which
one it shows.
I think it might--
well, I'm not even going
to guess, because--
RICH HYNDMAN: Why don't you
check, Wiebe, and tell us.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, you
can check and tell us.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I'm
checking right now.
ELLIE POWERS: Cool.
Yeah, it only works on an
application where you've
released multiple
versions of it.
So after you've released your
second version, you'll have
some grey dots on there.
And that's basically all
we have for today.
That's all of our
new features.
But I hope the message to any
developers out there listening
is, keep using the new
Developer Console.
Click the feedback link.
Let us know what you think.
And we have a team here in
London that's working to make
more improvements, so even if
you're looking for something
that isn't there yet, it still
could come out pretty soon.
So just keep telling us what
you think, and we'll keep
working on it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
And if there's any reason why
you haven't switched from the
old Developer Console to the new
one, just let us know on
Google+ straightaway.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
we definitely like
to hear those comments.
And if you're having any
problems, we want to make sure
that the support team figures
them out for you.
RICH HYNDMAN: The new Developer
Console is supposed
to be all-encompassing.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Just to let
everyone know, the version
code is what I see as a
grey dot on the graph.
ELLIE POWERS: So it's
version code.
Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
ELLIE POWERS: I'm going
to make a note.
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, that's it
for this week's Android
Developer Office Hours.
I want to go and play with
the new console.
It's going to be half an hour
before I can try all these
little things out.
OK.
Before we fire off into the
Moderator, has anybody from
the Hangout got a question?
There's a few things down
in the chat window.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm just bumping
up the text size.
I couldn't read it.
ELLIE POWERS: We saw someone
saying it would be good if it
showed the version name as
well as the version code.
OK.
I'll take that note.
RICH HYNDMAN: Quite
literally noted.
Look at us, all staring
at the screen.
Should we get better glasses?
This is incredible.
MALE SPEAKER: Everyone's
saying [INAUDIBLE]
version name.
NICK BUTCHER: Interesting.
Well, all right then.
RICH HYNDMAN: First one
to version eight.
NICK BUTCHER: Well,
thank you, Ellie.
You heard it here first.
News breaking.
ELLIE POWERS: Should I stick
around, or are you
guys good to go?
RICH HYNDMAN: You're welcome
to stick around, because
there's a question
in the Moderator.
ELLIE POWERS: Oh, well, we'll
see if any questions come up.
NICK BUTCHER: Should I go
straight to that one?
RICH HYNDMAN: Go on then.
We'll go straight to the
Moderator question, which
Ellie will probably say she
had to [INAUDIBLE].
ELLIE POWERS: Is it a question
about our future roadmap?
CHRIS BANES: Well, Hans Peter
has said, "When will you start
publishing regional Android
version distribution lists, in
addition to the global ones?
ELLIE POWERS: I've never--
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, hold on,
this isn't related to the
Developer Console.
ELLIE POWERS: No, it doesn't
sound like--
RICH HYNDMAN: See, I thought
this was the person asking to
be able to do regional
APKs or something.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah.
Is this a version of Android
that would be able to--
RICH HYNDMAN: This is like which
country has the most Ice
Cream Sandwiches [INAUDIBLE].
ELLIE POWERS: Oh, looking
for data.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry, that's
not Developer Console.
And yeah, that's something
we won't talk about.
Or can't.
We have no information.
NICK BUTCHER: But if you
look at something
like Distomo, is it?
ELLIE POWERS: Distimo?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Distimo,
that's it.
They put out some pretty
interesting stats.
Or what's the other one?
Stats Counter.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
The best way to get this
information is to publish an
app on the Play store.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: You get access
to everything then.
Publish it and make it
successful in every
country in the world.
You can find out all
the statistics.
MATT GAUNT: It's that easy.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Or have a botnet
all over the world, and
see those devices.
RICH HYNDMAN: Or look out for
something like Distimo that
[INAUDIBLE] publish them.
NICK BUTCHER: Or [INAUDIBLE]
and people like that.
They have some interesting
stats that
aren't terribly off.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
[INAUDIBLE] if we don't have
any other questions
[INAUDIBLE].
What else have we got
in the Moderator?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Everybody's
looking at you, Chris.
RICH HYNDMAN: Just set up a
meeting between Andrew Kelly
and Chris each week.
Because [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Andy's
here isn't he?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, yeah.
He had a camera when he jumped
in, but then he muted it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Black and
white on the far left.
CHRIS BANES: So Andrew Kelly has
asked, he's implementing a
new filter for the array data,
and it seems to be
particularly cumbersome, because
most [INAUDIBLE]
tunnels are private.
He's switched [INAUDIBLE] data,
but do I have any tips
for using the array
data to do this?
Not really, as such.
It shouldn't be much different
to use an array data as it
would be a beta data.
The only difference is you won't
have direct access to
the sort of collection.
But you can use data rates as
you normally would by using
getSize and getItem.
And it's right through.
So yeah, it shouldn't
be much different.
Can't think of a way
it really would.
So yeah.
If you want to chime in?
RICH HYNDMAN: He might chat
in the side window
unless we carry on.
Unless you want me to
[INAUDIBLE] the G+ stream open
at the same time.
CHRIS BANES: So yeah, I can't
really think of much sort of
difficult with it.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Excellent.
What's now?
Have you seen anything
that you--
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
questions.
So someone's asking when will
subscriptions come to In-app
Billing version 2, the answer
which is, last week.
ELLIE POWERS: Version
3, right?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
version 3, sorry.
From v2 into v3, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, just like
the new Developer Console
that's all-encompassing, the
In-app Billing v3 is now also
all-encompassing.
There's no reason you
should be using v2.
V3 is better in every
single way.
NICK BUTCHER: A lot easier for
you to implement as well, so
there's a lot fewer gotchas
and things you
have to be aware of.
CHRIS BANES: I did see one
gotcha the other day.
I mean, there's no more
unmanaged items.
RICH HYNDMAN: Correct.
ELLIE POWERS: That's right.
CHRIS BANES: So they're
all managed.
ELLIE POWERS: It's a
blessing and curse.
Mostly a blessing.
CHRIS BANES: So if you have an
unmanaged item now, you have
to consume the item to
actually use it.
So I've had a couple of
partners who've--
RICH HYNDMAN: Asking how
to consume items?
CHRIS BANES: Well, they didn't
know that they had to.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So switch to v3
without reading the docs.
Interesting.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
That's about the only one.
And other than that, it should
be a lot easier.
CHRIS BANES: Yes.
MATT GAUNT: Someone saying, "Is
there an ETA for In-app
Billing version 4?"
ELLIE POWERS: Version 4?
RICH HYNDMAN: That was the
question we just answered.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, OK.
Everyone's getting version
numbers mixed up.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
this one.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm going take
one from the floor.
If anybody in the Hangout has a
question, get ready for it.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I posted this
on Google+ as well.
Is there a good alternative
for the left menu
bar on a Google TV?
There's a lot of complaints
that it isn't the right
navigation field for a TV.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, so there's
no real good solution.
I think what we're seeing
a lot of developers do,
especially when you look at
someone like Amazon, et
cetera-- like, they start just
going down the route of making
quite a custom UI, in
terms of what makes
sense to their content.
I think the general thing that
we're trying to encourage
developers to do is only show
the relevant information based
on where the user's focusing.
Try and keep the UI as clean
and as basic and kind of as
attractive as possible, and
then start showing them
additional information depending
on where they're
focusing, because that's
going to be
the main way to interact.
So yeah.
I don't have a perfect solution
to avoid using the
left nav bar.
The biggest thing is to try and
avoid that navigation trap
when you're using
the action bar.
Because you're using up and down
along with the list view,
et cetera, it's going to
run into problems.
But we don't have a
perfect solution.
I have played with some of
the slide in drawers.
They do work on Google TV.
We started playing around with
the idea of having the menu
button to kind of slide it open
and close it, which is an
OK design paradigm, but
obviously, you have to kind of
train the user to do it.
And then you start running into
issues of, is that the
right thing or not?
And it kind of starts going
against the way you'd use it
on tablets and phones.
NICK BUTCHER: Why was
it focused then?
MATT GAUNT: Well, the default
thing is, you can actually
make it so that when you focus
to the left, and then you get
to the point where you're on
the edge of the screen, it
will open it for you.
And then when you focus out,
it will close it for you.
So that's in the--
NICK BUTCHER: So if you use the
menu button to open it,
does it then focus it as well?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
You can do it because you're
programmatically doing it.
But yeah.
It's one of those things
we were playing with.
You can do it that way, but
I'm not entirely convinced
it's a great kind of
user experience.
So those are kind of the main
things that I've seen people
trying to do.
But I don't have a
perfect solution.
Not one that I'd say,
definitely go
down this route, yeah.
WIEBE ELSINGA: OK.
Shame.
MATT GAUNT: I know.
CHRIS BANES: I'll answer
Andy's question.
So Andy has asked, "How secure
is data stored in shared
preferences when using mode
private?" And he's asked, "Is
it worth doing encryption?"
So, mode private basically
makes the firewalls only
accessible to your user
ID as an app.
So if there are other apps that
are sharing your user ID,
they can access those files.
If the device is rooted, sort of
a rooted app could actually
access those files too.
So it depends on the
context of the
information that you're storing.
But it's sort of up
to you, really.
NICK BUTCHER: And if you're
talking about encryption, then
you get down to then,
where are you going
to store the key?
So you might just end up moving
the problem, rather
than solving the problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: And there's some
great guidelines published
yesterday by Trevor Johns on the
Android Developers Blog,
which say don't create and
store the key beforehand.
Make sure you create it on the
device after run time and then
store it, so that if someone
does get hold of the key, it
obviously doesn't apply to every
single instance of your
application.
He says store the salt
for the key in local.
NICK BUTCHER: And that is
relying on your user ID to
protect it.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then
regenerate the key
when you need it.
Use Secure Random.
A few other things that
he's put in there.
So there's a blog post that's
currently on Android
Developers Blog Blogspot.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, obviously
these are all defeated if
users have rooted
their devices.
So I'd say, yeah, it comes out
to if it's like your banking
information or something like
that, then probably don't
store it on the device.
Like, anything super secure--
because it's not a trusted
computing platform at the end
of the day.
People have access to
this information.
So depends on the information.
RICH HYNDMAN: What is
secure these days?
Store the hashes or whatever
you need to access your
service on the device, but
don't secure plain text
passwords [INAUDIBLE].
Don't store passwords or reverse
engineerable versions
of passwords.
That would be crazy.
We've got a few people asking
about IABv2 bugs.
We do know there was a lot
of issues with IABv2.
Messages were bundled up, a
lot of developers wouldn't
read them all.
It was very hard to debug a lot
of the IABv2 issues, so
obviously, the answer is, if
you're having IABv2 issues,
please, please, please
switch to IABv3.
That's what it's there for.
And [? Sika ?]
is asking something in
the chat window.
"Can we answer questions
in chat?" Yes we can.
ELLIE POWERS: There's a
follow-up question at the
bottom from [? Sika. ?]
RICH HYNDMAN: "Is it possible
to clear programmatically
Google Chrome cache on Android?"
I think not.
You can send someone to the app
info for Chrome, and they
can choose to press the
Clear Cache button.
But I don't believe that you
could add-- no, no no.
You can send them to the app
info, and they can clear the
cache and the data there.
But you can't from your
application go ahead and start
clearing other applications'
data.
It would also be against the
developer distribution
agreement, which says you're not
allowed to interfere with
the behavior of other
applications.
NICK BUTCHER: And also in the
sidebar, Giuseppe's asked two
questions about the
Developer Console.
He asks, he would like contact
information for crashes for
the user who incurred a crash.
Which is interesting [INAUDIBLE]
supports.
So thanks for that suggestion.
And number two, he says, "When
will we get reply to review?"
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, this is
a really common question.
I guess what we're doing right
now is we're rolling it out
gradually to more developers
over time.
And sorry that you don't
have it yet.
We have been making some tweaks
to the feature as we do
roll it out, so hopefully by
the time we do get it out
more, it'll be a better
experience for both
developers and users.
So please hold tight.
Sorry about the delays.
NICK BUTCHER: Back in the
Moderator, Nick in Chicago
asks-- he says he has a GLView
on top of two VideoViews,
which he switches to go
from an intro video
to a looping video.
And in between, he gets a black
screen flash, which is
the background actually
bleeding through.
And how to make it gapless.
And Chris has posted a link to
Stack Overflow [INAUDIBLE],
which is very, very good.
Just to add a little bit
of context to that.
So a surface view is actually a
hole in your view hierarchy,
and the reason we do this is
because normally, you're
playing videos, and in order to
not have to recomposite the
whole thing when we're trying
to get it into the window,
it's much more efficient
to render it like this.
So it takes one less copy, and
you can play videos at a much
higher frame rate, and
so on and so forth.
But yeah.
The consequence of that is that
it's not part of your
view hierarchy.
So you get these strange things
where something might
bleed through from having
this hole in it.
So yeah, you can't actually
get around
the whole black flash.
You can't avoid it happening.
But what you can is
work around it.
So you can put something
on top of it.
So you can put a view on top of
your surface view, right?
And so, during the transition,
you might put fade to black
view on top, switch out the
video view underneath, and
face that view back out to
transparency to give the
impression of a gapless
playback.
So it's just a consequence
of using that.
And the alternative is you could
take a look at texture
view, which is available since
Ice Cream Sandwich?
Yes, API 11.
No, 14.
Sorry.
Honeycomb.
But that does involve an extra
memory copy, so you might want
to not use that for your entire
video playback, or test
it to see how the
performance is.
MATT GAUNT: Nailed it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ooh.
Someone's just destroyed
our chat.
Hopefully if you had a question
in the chat, it just
refreshed it.
CHRIS BANES: I think it's meant
to do reverb and why
don't we support another
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
They work very well for Android
development, and some
people do use IntelliJ for their
Android development.
But yeah, the primary focus
of the tools team--
they have to focus
on something, and
they focused on Eclipse.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] come
in from [INAUDIBLE] in Israel.
He says--
RICH HYNDMAN: He's just
joined us live?
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: You want to
ask your question live,
[INAUDIBLE]?
RICH HYNDMAN: Obviously not.
ELLIE POWERS: Is he muted?
MATT GAUNT: I think he is.
ELLIE POWERS: If you're
muted, can you unmute?
MATT GAUNT: Nope.
Not working.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, he's not
muted on the Hangout.
ELLIE POWERS: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Anyway, if you
manage to make noise, then you
can chime in, [INAUDIBLE].
But until then, I'll crack on
with what you've written in
the Moderator.
So you asked, you'd like to load
a NinePatch image from a
remote server.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
My question, exactly.
You got me?
NICK BUTCHER: You want
to ask it live?
Go for it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, sure.
We all know that usually we
have image views that get
their images remotely.
And I want to try to
do that with a
NinePatch image, basically.
So in order to do that, I've
digged a lot in resources--
resource types .h and do
NinePatch and all that.
And I understood that I either
need to compile the .9.png on
the server side before I hand
it down to my application.
I couldn't find a utility
that will do that.
There is some way to hack APT
to do that, but it's not
something that I can rely on in
the production environment.
And so I looked for another way,
and that's to basically
compile the .9.png file in real
time on the fly in my
application, which means
drifting down and to extract
two pixels on each dimension,
and create a new PNG file and
a [INAUDIBLE]
array, and then use the
NinePatchDrawable interface or
API, basically, to create the
NinePatch programmatically.
I am ashamed to say that
I failed to succeed.
I couldn't do that.
I mean, I've tried for about a
week, and I couldn't find any
resource on the net
to do that, or
any other leads there.
So any help will be greatly
appreciated.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, there
is no supported way
of doing this, really.
No officially supported way.
It definitely has
been documented.
There was a question similar to
this a couple of weeks ago
on this show, and there was
a couple of Stack Overflow
threads which were linked.
So someone has worked out
[INAUDIBLE], but there's a
[INAUDIBLE] array that you
can sort of decode
the resource wave.
It'll actually do it for you.
But I can't remember off
the top of my head.
I'll have to look and
then reply later.
So yeah.
I'll have a look and sort of
reply after this show.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we have
had this question before.
I have passed it around
the Android team.
I've [INAUDIBLE] as well, and
the resounding response has
been that there isn't a
supported way of doing it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: But why not
do the [INAUDIBLE]
to take care of all the
files on the server?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, the problem
with that is, you're then at
the whim of network
compression, all
that kind of stuff.
So if the network mangled
your file in between--
MALE SPEAKER: I couldn't
hear that.
CHRIS BANES: So if you're on a
mobile network, most mobile
networks compress images.
So if I compress
your NinePatch,
it won't work anymore.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
So just do a secure way to
transfer the files in parts,
like a multi-part encoded
in base 64, maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: I know how to
bypass the mobile network
compression things.
Everything is secured in
Talon, so the mobile
[INAUDIBLE]
doesn't know what I'm
passing there.
They have no way to
touch my data.
I know that because
[INAUDIBLE]
mobile operator that if you're
trying to do [INAUDIBLE]
so I'm funneling everything.
So as for [INAUDIBLE], so
the mobile operator
won't touch my data.
So I know that I'll get the
PNG file [INAUDIBLE]
on server.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah.
Just looking at the time, we're
down to the last five
minutes of today's Hangout.
Maybe have a quick look
at the next page
and clear the Moderator.
Has anybody got anything urgent
they want to get in
before the end of the Hangout?
MATT GAUNT: Silence.
RICH HYNDMAN: Any more questions
from inside the chat
or the Hangout as we just
look through the
last couple of questions?
CHRIS BANES: Andrew
Kelly has asked
about Google I/O tickets.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Buy one.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS BANES: You've got
the right idea.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: So someone's
asking, "Is there a design
pattern for synchronizing rows
of data between disparate
systems, between different
devices, in particular,
without having conflicting key
identifiers?" Because they're
using UUID.
"But I think they will not
work for a large system.
Any comments?"
Interesting.
So there's a bunch of different
things you could do.
I don't know how you're actually
synchronizing between
your devices.
I don't know if you're using
some kind of back end system
like App Engine, or whether--
you could build something
like this.
We gave a workshop on how to use
Google Drive, for example,
to synchronize data between the
two devices, and Dropbox
just launched a similar API for
Android to help you to do
syncing of data between
devices.
But when you're talking about
the actual key creations, so
like, if you're creating an
object on two devices, and you
want them to not collide,
then, yeah.
It makes sense to either use
some kind of [? GUI, ?] or I
think the way Drive actually
does it is it doesn't have an
identifier until you
try and upload it.
And when you upload it, Drive
will give you a unique
identifier.
So you could use something
like that, perhaps.
If I've understood the
question correctly.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
You can generate something--
NICK BUTCHER: [? With GUI, ?]
right?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: --random
or with a timestamp.
So it will be completely
unique.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Was somebody else-- no, I
think-- there we go, yeah.
Who's that in the chat--
in the Hangout there?
CHRIS BANES: I think it's
Carson [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Nothing to say?
Yeah.
Unless anybody else has any--
oh, hi.
Hi.
Hello?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so I have
a question [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: We're having
trouble hearing you.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Sure, go ahead.
Just speak slowly, because--
MALE SPEAKER: OK, [INAUDIBLE]
systems.
I am trying to [INAUDIBLE].
ELLIE POWERS: Oh, OK.
Now we can see.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, if you could
type the question into
the chat window.
We're having a bit of trouble
hearing what you're saying.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
WIEBE ELSINGA: The guy
said, just did it.
It was the question about
the cache for Chrome.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah, we answered that, that
it was impossible.
Personally, if I was looking
for that, I would plug the
device in, go to the app info,
and see which intent was fired
to get [INAUDIBLE] info.
Then put that intent inside my
application, so when you fire
it off, the user gets taken
to Chrome's app info.
Chrome probably supports the
intent for going directly to
storage settings as well.
NICK BUTCHER: It's probably not
documented, so it could
change, obviously.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, that's true.
It's a good point.
All right then.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
OK.
So I think that brings us to the
end of our time this week.
So thank you, everyone, who's
pre-submitted the questions.
I hope you're enjoying the
new shorter format.
Hopefully we get through quite
a lot of content, and it's
easier for you to re-watch
later as well.
So, as always, we prefer
questions pre-submitted in
advance into the Moderator
queue.
So if you have any questions,
or we didn't get around to
your question, please do submit
it for next week.
And thanks for everyone who
joined us live, and for
joining in and asking
great questions in
the sidebar or live.
And we will see you again
same time next week.
MALE SPEAKER: And
the week after.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: All right now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WIEBE ELSINGA: Thanks
for the console.
The new one.
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
Glad you like it.
NICK BUTCHER: Everyone
loves the console.